If an adopted individual wanted to find his or her parents,
they might choose to look by signing up for a genome
service that will get their genome's information and compare it to
everyone else's genome in the system to see if there's a match.
For example, you'd imagine we might just take some of the
sequence from the adopted person and compare it letter for letter, to
a sequence from a random person. We could even do the
comparisons with a lot of random people. But there are three billion
base pairs in every genome. Six billion once you
count both copies of all your chromosomes from each parent.
So doing a letter by letter comparison of the
whole thing would take such a long time and a
lot of computational power. Instead, the general technique used
for comparisons is similar to that used to match DNA
at crime scenes, or even in paternity tests. It involves
the general statistical process known as sampling. Sampling is concerned
with the selection of a subset of individuals
from within a population. To estimate characteristics about the
whole population. In this case instead of looking
at all three billion letters in the human genome,
we'll select a random subset of letters, let's
say a million from one genome and compare the
same subset from one genome to another. So
if we do this random sampling. What do you
think are two advantages of random sampling compared to total
genome sequencing? Make sure you check two of the answers.